what's going on how are you have you
seen this yet I have seen it I saw last
night because we did a fancy reading and
so we surprised the fans and then Ana
Cathcart who plays kitty we stayed in
the back and we watched okay so it's
coming up Valentine's Day in it around
there you know that this movie is going
to be the focal point of anybody's
Valentine's Day evening set the rest of
the night what is the perfect way on
Valentine's Day for two people who are
in love to consume this movie okay for
two people who are in love or two people
who maybe aren't in love for two people
who maybe want to one day be in love
that's like that's a juicier question
okay um okay so sit on the couch yes I
hope that you can project from you know
your tablet or your computer onto like
your television yes you can see a little
bit bigger yes and have two glasses of
wine okay and oh and some popcorn
with nutritional yeast on it that's my
favorite way to eat and have a pillow in
between each other because then like you
can kind of like you know like you put
your hand down
like yeah oh my god lovelies I don't
like it so your codes okay set the mood
and I think that's the best way to
digest the movie um people have always
said specially young people who are in
high school
god why isn't my life like the movies
and now you've created one of those
movies or two of those movies how do you
feel about that that you are now the
example setter for people who are like
why isn't my life like hers um how do I
feel about that you know I think that I
am very proud of large eeen because I
think she's a good person
so if people are looking at her and and
are like I find that people either they
typically want to be her best friend and
I I'm proud of that because I'm like yes
you want to be friends with good people
like you don't need that negativity in
your life and I think she has a lot of
love to give so I I don't know I think I
feel good about it I I'm proud of the
movie and I'm proud of what it
represents so um you know that Noah's
doing he man Jordan does a voice in
Shira are you at all interested yourself
and getting in that world it seems
perfect
in the world of like of he-man and Shera
of humanity I mean yeah I listen I have
the majority of my work is based off of
comics so I felt like yeah why was an
x-men I did like a lead of battle angel
and so I've done I've done a lot of that
world and in terms of like being in that
comic world and I love it I think it's
it's completely different from to all
the voice but I love working in stunts
that's my favorite thing ever
yeah um so yeah I would love to keep
doing that um people you are the example
you are in this film she is so kind and
just open and generous and then you have
the two boys who I'm in the room last
night of the screening and it's working
people it's journalists right we all
know better they show up on the screen
and there's serious shrieking right I
know okay like there's there's shrieking
like this movie has created a monster
with those two are they comfortable with
that have you seen what it does to them
have they tried to navigate that world
of shrieking there do you goof on them
for that they're doing a really great
great job I mean with Jordan like Jordan
I he's new to the movie like I think
that the tall the boys family and those
fan bases they're there he hasn't even
gotten like as I'm like that he they
love him but they haven't seen the movie
yet so you just right but you know know
it does a great great job and he he he's
he's very he's a very confident guy and
but he has a lot of love to give so when
people are like oh my god he's so lovely
he always gives people hugs and he and
and he's always so kind to them and I
think he's handled himself really really
well in the past year and a half in the
way that because his life changed right
Oliver's did you're a role model now
kids dress up as you for Halloween what
is that like that was crazy that first
Halloween I was you know seeing all
these photos come through and and mom's
dressing up they're like baby babies and
their dogs and then girls dressing up
and then girls with their boyfriends and
girls with their husbands and everything
and that was the greatest moment because
it it broke my heart a little cuz I
wanted how do I have Larry and when I
was little
I absolutely would have dressed up like
her and so having kind of that there's a
great quote in in the book where it's
like you know I dressed up as the girl
from Harry with the Asian girl from
Harry Potter because there's a lot of
fictional characters that I could have
dressed up it's for Halloween
so seeing like from the book it's seen
that quote to real life and see girls
dress up as large it was just like it
just meant so much to me because I was
like I would have done that I would have
done that whatever little amazing thank
you so much